hey youtubers it's Charlie this week is
gonna be all about house Tyrell you know
what's going on right now in the story
all the way back to Aegon's conquest
they originally did not start out as a
very powerful house even though marjorie
is the queen right now it's really the
queen of thorns that everyone points to
when they think of house Tyrell the show
has just made some changes to the way
that they're portrayed in the books
they're still heavily featured in the
books just in slightly different ways
it's just the one they cast like really
big actors who are amazing they they
want to feature them more so like Diana
Rigg gets a bunch of scenes that she
didn't get in the books if it's not
clear she's Marjorie's grandmother she's
mace Tyrells mother who is Marjorie's
father just a reminder to new round of
the giveaway starts now all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video just a $20
Amazon gift card of all the great houses
in Westeros though you know just in
terms of sheer assets not necessarily
you Rob monetary wealth the Tyrells are
the most powerful
the Lannisters do have their gold mines
which are now running dry or have run
dry but the Tyrells they controlled the
most fertile land the starts
historically controlled the north which
is like a larger geographical area but
the land the Tyrells control is much
more valuable it's the place where most
of the Seven Kingdoms grain comes from
the stuff that they don't import from
Essos that's why during season five the
Queen of thorns threatened Cersei to cut
her off say you know we're not gonna
ship you any grain anymore she was
essentially telling Cersei that she was
going to starve out the crown but mostly
King's Landing but the crown really she
can make good on that threat too because
the Tyrells command the largest army and
they have a fleet of ships you know from
the red wine that's the house she comes
from they have a fleet that's supposed
to be just as big as the Crown's fleet
so they have a ton of ships and a ton of
soldiers if they wanted to they could
actually make war with the crown and
make pretty quick work of them assuming
that the other great houses don't rally
behind the crown so if it's not apparent
from from what's been happening on the
show to Tyrells are legit powerful in in
considering that the Lannisters gold is
drying up they're gonna be the
wealthiest family in Westeros really
fast right now there's still the second
most wealthy behind the Lannisters their
house motto is growing stronger and they
have very literally done that for their
entire house history but they weren't
originally part of the first men like
they didn't start out as kings of the
reach the Tyrells do trace their lineage
back to house gardener although it's
only through marriage technically they
come from an Andale but the reach was
originally ruled by house gardener
started by Garth the gardener who was
son of the mythical high king of the
first men Garth greenhand he along with
like land the clever
bran the Builder were like like the
mythical kings of the first men back
during the Age of Heroes the dates are a
little fuzzy like history is it isn't
recorded perfectly when it goes that far
back so you assume that they lived
together but it's possible that some of
them overlapped so like land the clever
supposed to be alive at the same time
that bran the Builder was but you know
maybe they were maybe they weren't just
for context though assuming that they
were all alive at the same time that was
about eight thousand years ago because
bran the Builder started building the
wall about 8,000 years ago George R
Martin has since clarified that they
were actual people so they lived normal
lifespans in the years after the long
night is as the wall was being built
Garth greenhand started house gardener
and started ruling over the reach house
Tyrell didn't become a thing till right
around the time of the Andal invasion
that period of time lasted for longer
than a God's conquest like Aegon's
conquest was about a two-year period
the Andal invasion was much much longer
so about three Gardner Kings came and
went while that was going on at the
conclusion of that the Gardner king of
the time raised in ándale knight named
Alistair Tyrell to his service and that
became the beginning of house Tyrell
it's one of the many examples of a great
house being born out of conflict House
Baratheon was another famous one that
started after Aegon's conquest after he
became King he raised or aspera thean
named him the lord of the Stormlands
lesson learned if he wind up on the
winning side of a major conflict in
Westeros you will make out pretty good
that actually reminds me of that tyrion
quote that he said to Joffrey before the
purple wedding Kings are dropping like
flies so when the Tyrell started out
they were just one of the many small
houses that were bound to house Gardner
but as part of that the Lord of the
House held a political office they were
named high stewards of Highgarden the
Gardner's ended up loving them so much
over the years that they made the office
hereditary but originally
started out as a political thing so in
the years after the forming of house
Tyrell they slowly rose to become like
the greatest of the lesser houses in the
reach there was even a time later when a
Tyrell became regent of the reach when a
new gardener King inherited the throne
at a really young age it's kind of like
what happens with Tommen Baratheon in
the books that's kind of an issue that
the show is sidestepped because they
aged Tommen way up because they wanted
this like sexy stuff going on with
Margaery in the books Tommen is still
like this really little kid that just
likes eating sweets and chasing his cat
around chasing sir pounce around the
castle it's actually really funny
because the small council still needs
like the royal seal of approval on some
things they let him stamp documents with
his royal seal and it's like a game like
picture a little kid playing with LEGOs
with with Jam all over his face that's
what book Tommen is like just like the
soul of innocence so for thousands of
years house Tyrell just kind of existed
is this satellite house of house Gardner
all the way up til Aegon's conquest what
ended up happening during that conflict
is that when Aegon marched on the reach
house Gardner had combined forces with
the Lannisters
but because Aegon had like a fraction of
their number what he did is he had his
dragons set the entire battlefield on
fire and all the gardener's like
literally the gardener king all of his
family all of his heirs were killed the
entire bloodline wiped out in the
aftermath when Aegon marched his army
down to Highgarden the Tyrells bent the
knee so they were raised up to Lords of
the reach their technical title became
Lord paramount of the Mandor that's just
the title given to the Lords of the
reach although technically they're also
called the wardens of the South just
like the Starks became wardens of the
north the reach itself is like one of
the biggest most interesting places in
Westeros that we haven't seen on the
show yet but you know by all accounts
they're filming locations for that in
season six most of that will probably
end up being an old town though a lot of
that area in and around the reach is
featured heavily in the dunk and egg
series though so if you want to read
stories that take place in that area
just read dunk an egg just thinking
about the future of the series because
the Tyrells really hate the Lannisters
right now it's possible that if Daenerys
were ever to march on Westeros the
Tyrells would rallied to her banner
and remember what I said the Tyrells are
capable of marshalling the largest army
so if you were gonna try and take
Westeros you would really want the
Tyrells on your side I think the real
question though is is like will the
Tyrells engage in open conflict with the
crown before that happens before
Daenerys decides to march on Westeros
there's still like so many questions I
just feel like even if they do skip a
lot of the side stories and a lot of the
side plots they still need like a full
season for the war for the dawn in like
another season to address Daenerys going
to Westeros like two different seasons
just for those big stories and as of
right now she hasn't given any
indication that she's ready to do that
she barely has control of slavers Bay so
here's my big question for you guys do
you think Daenerys is going to march on
Westeros and try to take the Iron Throne
then deal with the war for the dawn and
the White Walkers or do you think it's
gonna happen the other way like do you
think that she's going to see the army
of White Walkers as a threat like
something someone will tell her about it
and she'll be like oh I have to deal
with this first before I deal with the
Iron Throne
so she'll write in like you know Stannis
did at the end of season 4 like she'll
just chill right into battle against the
White Walkers and then the other Great
Houses will say okay well she's not an
invader she's trying to help us so we'll
help her out I feel like in that
scenario the Great Houses would be much
quicker to march into battle with
Daenerys against the White Walkers
seeing her is more of a savior than an
invader then unlike the aftermath of of
whatever you know final conflict they
have with the White Walkers she can
decide what she's gonna do with the rest
of the Seven Kingdoms
really I think the scenario that's more
likely is that the White Walkers will
Cole a lot of Westeros before Daenerys
marches on them so Westeros as we know
it right now will be somewhat shattered
by the time Daenerys marches in so
whoever ends up walking away from that
conflict will be tasked with rebuilding
Westeros not so much conquering it so
just a quick reminder comic-con is
coming up in about 10 days or so I'll
probably do a preview video sometime
next week or the week after that that'll
just explain what kind of Game of
Thrones stuff I'll be doing during that
week some of you guys have been asking
about a meet-up there will be a meet-up
I just I don't know which day it's gonna
be on ER or what time it's gonna be at I
just have to see the full Comic Con
schedule before I know when I'm gonna
have some free time I've been going to
since about 2006 but for the past like
three or four years I've been going for
work so it's like it's a little bit
different this year it seems like it's
gonna be a little bit more laid-back
than last year just because so many film
companies aren't going so it might be a
little bit more chill I'm actually
really excited about that you have never
seen so many people standing in so many
different lines that's really what
comic-con is a lot of standing in line
but like a short amount of time actually
seeing the thing that you're standing in
line for a lot of you guys have been
asking me about Arthur Dayne so I think
my next bonus video is gonna be about
him so I might post that later this week
I don't know if I'll wait till Sunday to
do that I am doing a Q&A tomorrow though
so just in case you guys haven't seen it
I've started doing videos for the
Walking Dead Season six you can click
here to get some some behind the scenes
footage and find out what's going on
with the first episode of that and you
can click here to learn about what's
going on with the Game of Thrones Season
six cast thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you